the NFL may be on the ropes and
President Trump may have put them there
the left demonstrates its definite scorn
for the middle of the country and we'll
talk about one of the worst movies ever
made I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show so the vortex of stupidity
continues to whirl and you are a part of
it my friends as am i there's no way to
escape the category-five stupid
hurricane that has descended upon the
United States and that continues each
and every day we'll talk about all of
the things but first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at Realty
shares it's not an offering of
securities private investments are
highly illiquid and risky not suitable
for all investors past performance not
indicative of future results securities
offered to accredited investors through
North capital private securities at
member finra s ipeec okay so if you are
a big boy or big girl it is time for you
start planning a for your future and
this means that you need to take some of
your money and put it in real estate the
best way to do this and not try to put
all your money in one place or drop
$200,000 on one apartment building is if
you have that kind of money is to go
over to my friends at realty shares
because what they do is they put
together a list of properties that they
have vetted projects that they have
vetted that they think are decent
investments and then they allow you to
invest in $5,000 increments invest
fractionally with hundreds of other
people to reduce the cost of an initial
investment Realty shares deals are
vetted they're curated by industry
professionals who under write and
perform details that due diligence so
you don't have to do that if you make
$200,000 a year you may qualify find out
today at realty shares dot-com / Ben
that's Realty shares calm / Ben and
right now they have a special offer for
our listeners if you go today to realty
shares calm / Ben you get $100 toward
your first investment so instead of
having to invest five grand
now it's 49 hundred bucks go today to
realty shares calm / Ben Rea lty shares
calm / Ben for $100 toward your first
investment again the only way that you
are going to be able to retire securely
if you are a young person or a
middle-aged person is not by relying on
social security which is a giant scam
it's by making good financial decisions
now one of those decisions is to invest
go to Realty shares calm / Ben okay so
the football controversy a default
controversy will not die
ratings were apparently slightly up on
Sunday over the previous year but that's
because people were tuning in to see the
controversy next week watch for the
ratings to plummet as people simply tune
out and demonstrate that they're not
interested in watching a bunch of
players who they feel are ungrateful for
being in the United States of America
and who are kneeling about the anthem
and the flag so one of the things that
I've been talking about for years on
this program now is the idea that two
bubbles have formed in the United States
it's not just one bubble you know we on
the right like to say well Hollywood's
its bubble media there that's their
bubble there are two bubbles there's the
bubble of those of us on the right and
the bubble of those of the people on the
left in the right
bubble we look at the people kneeling
and we say everyone who's kneeling is
doing so because they hate the Anthem in
the flag right the reason that you kneel
during the anthem is because you don't
like the anthem and you think that
America is a is a problematic place
imbued inherently with racism sexism
bigotry and homophobia and that's why
you're kneeling it's because you don't
like the flag and and there's some
evidence to this Colin Kapernick when he
first knelt said I'm doing this because
the flag doesn't stand for black
Americans which is just absurd it's just
asinine it was the flag of the United
States that was carried into battle by
the black regiment during the Civil War
that you can see it in the movie glory
you know the flag has always stood for
the Constitution and the Declaration of
Independence and the development toward
a better America that's what the flag
has always stood for which is why smart
civil rights protesters back in the
1960s weren't burning the flag they were
marching with the flag and saying this
is our flag this is our America that's a
smart way to protest a stupid way to
protest is to kneel through the national
anthem and to kneel as the as the flag
is honored this she's a dumb way to do
it so if they're on the right the way
that you see this battle is all the
people who are kneeling originally we're
kneeling because they don't like the
country and the people who are kneeling
with them today are probably kneeling
because they also don't really like the
country too much then there's the way
the left reads this which is people are
kneeling because they think the country
is not all that it can be and they are
kneeling to demonstrate that the flag is
not really being upheld
even though symbolically it matters it's
because it matters symbolically that we
have to protest it and therefore that's
that's why Kaepernick and company we're
nailing originally and now all the
people who are kneeling now it's not
even because they agree with Kaepernick
it's because they don't like the
president Trump called for a boycott of
the NFL and called for the NFL to fire
everyone who is kneeling so there are
two reasons for the kneeling
reason number one is because America
just isn't what it's supposed to be it's
not all it's cracked up to be so Neil
for the national anthem and reason
number two is to protest Trump okay and
these two visions of what exactly is
happening it demonstrates it's sort of
like the movie Rashomon I mean is it's
it there's there's a bunch of there
multiple viewers of a single event and
they're each taking what they what they
want from that event on the right we're
taking away there are a lot of people
who don't like the country on the Left
they're taking away that they're a bunch
of people who want to stand against
America's fundamental values and
kneeling is the way to protest those
people right so that's the actual that
that's actually what's going on from an
objective if you're an alien coming in
from outer space watching all of this
this is what you would say right there's
a bunch of different perspectives on the
same event now I tend to think a few
things one kneeling for the national
anthem is done kneeling for the flag is
done again you'd be better off grabbing
the flag and saying this is my flag I
stand with the flag against these forces
that stand against American values so
the kneeling is stupid the it's just
it's it's pointless and it's it's bad PR
on the other hand the people who are
kneeling yesterday are not quite the
same thing or Sunday not quite the same
thing as Colin Kaepernick kneeling
they're not all the same people Colin
Kaepernick was basically kneeling by
himself by the end of his career and the
people who are kneeling yesterday a lot
of them were people who were not on
board with Colin Kaepernick kneeling for
the anthem in the first place but they
wanted to show solidarity for the right
to kneel right in the same way that you
sometimes see people sort of spite
protest in order to in order to piss off
the other side so there's some of that
going on too
okay so let's see how this plays out so
you can see that on a political level
this is very beneficial for Trump and
pence so president Trump is has an
arrant inerrant nose for the controversy
that is most likely to polarize the
country in his favor he's actually quite
good at this and he's done it repeatedly
so the left claimed after the travel ban
Oh Americans hate the travel ban it's
just gonna be terrible for Trump to
travel ban the travel ban wasn't
terrible for Trump most Americans were
fine with the travel ban the left
doesn't understand that the left doesn't
understand that when President Trump
says polarizing things on a wide variety
of topics when he says that when we need
a sort of macho posturing most Americans
don't care about that and the left
doesn't understand the one Trump says
Colin Kaepernick is an sob for kneeling
during the anthem there are a lot of
Americans who feel the same way
and when people Neil Trump wins that
battle and you can see how the right is
trying to frame the battle as don't
protest the flag on the national anthem
and the left is trying to protest is
trying to frame the entire debate as a
debate about the First Amendment so
here's Mike Pence framing it in terms of
the flag in the national anthem we've
all got a right to our opinions but I
don't think it's too much to ask the
players in the National Football League
to stand for our national anthem and I
know the people of Alabama great because
you know patriotism is what unites us
it's about respect for the flag respect
for the country and most importantly
it's about respect for all those who
fought and died to defend it and I think
the Pence is exactly right of course
which is why I've always opposed flag
burning and kneeling on the flag and and
pictures of Bill Ayers standing on the
flag I think it's disgusting I think I
think all of that is quite gross so this
is how the rights attempting to frame it
you see groups like the NRA doing the
same thing the NRA released an ad
yesterday last night that essentially
says the same thing for the land of the
free and the home of the brave from high
school gyms to towering stadiums every
time I see our flag wave I feel a
humbling reminder of the brave who keep
and have kept us free I stand to honor
the sacrifices of the generations before
me heroes who charge in the battle
through bombs and bullets who lost their
brothers and still push through fighting
for every inch of our freedom
I stand for my brothers who can't stand
anymore
men who hunted terrorists to the ends of
the earth who sacrificed their bodies
and their lives so that we could
peacefully live ours
I stand for the children the spouses and
parents whose family made the friendly
happens here right and it's actually a
quite good ad here right this is this is
an attempt to frame this specifically as
all the people kneeling are doing a
disservice to service members and
spouses and children of people who have
died in combat protecting the flag and
protecting our national unity right
that's the way the right is framing us
now here's the way the left is friend
mean it's like we're living in two
separate worlds we're living in two
separate worlds here's Hillary Clinton
framing this in a completely different
way it's as though you're watching two
separate narratives happening at the
same time protest is a part of the
American Way of life and it's something
that I'm very proud of whether I agree
or disagree I think peaceful protest is
part of what has helped us make progress
learn more be a better country over time
okay and this is what I don't like about
what President Trump did is that these
were both principles that we generally
believed right pretty much all Americans
believe this they should stand for the
flag you shouldn't disrespect the flag
shouldn't disrespect the anthem and also
that what Hillary Clinton is saying
about peaceful protest is basically
correct that we in America have always
valued peaceful protests we've always
valued dissent we think that that's a
valuable thing but now the left has
basically grabbed hold of the dissents
his patriotism banner and the right is
grabs hold of the actual banner and now
they're going to war with each other is
that good for the country I don't think
it's good for the country at all and
then the left takes it too far
so if that were the only battle then I
would say okay easy consensus right easy
to come together about this very simple
we can bridge this gap immediately stop
kneeling for the anthem and or at least
or at least I understand why we
criticize you for kneeling for the
anthem it's bad to kneel for the anthem
and also if you want to kneel for the
anthem you know that's your business but
we have a right to criticize you for
doing so very easy consensus but then
Hillary Clinton decides to take this
even further and I'll explain that in
just a second but first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at the
u.s. ECA so can you say with
percent confidence that you and your
family are safe what if you pull the
trigger too soon what if something
breaks in your house and you pull the
trigger too soon do you know what to say
do you know what to do with your gun
when the police arrive so that you're
not arrested and carted off to prison
well here's how you can take a simple
rewarding journey to concealed carry and
home defense confidence it's called the
2017 concealed carry and family defense
guide it's from the u.s. concealed carry
Association it is 100% free
you'll learn how to detect attackers
before they see you how to survive a
mass shooting the safest and most
dangerous places to sit in a restaurant
how to responsibly own and store a gun
and a whole lot more it's 164 pages and
it comes with a bonus audio version so
you can even listen to it in the car you
finish my podcast and pop that right in
this life changing guides a hundred
percent free and for a limited time you
also get a bonus home defense checklist
so go to defend my family now calm for
all of that defend my family now calm
for 100% free instant access to that
hundred and sixty four page guide defend
my family now calm they provide you all
the resources that you need in order to
protect your family and in case god
forbid you actually have to shoot
somebody who is who is coming into your
home to make sure that you and your
family are protected in every
conceivable way okay so as I say the
normal battle should be it should be
easy to fix standing for the national
anthem is appropriate kneeling is
inappropriate but this is America you're
allowed to do it everybody calm down
right that's that's the easiest way to
do this Trump overstepped on the one end
by using the flag to bash people who are
who were kneeling to the extent same
that they ought to be fired and then
Hillary Clinton oversteps her boundaries
not by defending the First Amendment by
then implying that anyone who opposes
people who kneel is a racist so here's
Hillary Clinton doing that routine
I think it's deeply troubling that the
president would be attacking black
athletes for expressing their opinions
peacefully okay attacking black athletes
as I said on Fox News last night
President Trump is pretty
equal-opportunity in who he attacks I
mean Hillary Clinton gets it on the chin
from president from virtually every
single day and she's been not a relevant
part of America's political scene for
nearly a year at this point so the idea
that Trump is only attacking black
athletes really I mean he was attacking
his own attorney general the same way
like six weeks ago so know that that
doesn't wash it all but again what we
have here is a difference
Louis CK's comedy routines adding Lucy
kids really funny he has a comedy
routine called
called of course but Mamie and his
comedy routine goes something like this
he says of course of course we all
understand that peanut allergies are
things that we should be careful of and
we should make sure that nobody around a
kid who has a peanut allergy should have
a peanut because we have to protect
those kids I mean it's just something we
have to do as a society of course we
have to do that but maybe if we just let
people carry around peanuts this would
all be over in a generation
right this is a dis Louie CK's routine
the problem that we have in politics
right now is that everybody is now doing
of course but maybe everybody is now
doing of course that may be so Trump is
saying things like of course it's bad
when people kneel for the anthem of
course and of course dissent is okay but
maybe all those people should be fired
because I mean if they got fired and
then no one would be kneeling for the
end of them and then on the other side
you have Hillary Clinton doing of course
but maybe of course the the flag is
important of course the national anthem
is a good thing of course that's true
but maybe president Trump is a brutal
racist but maybe he's a Breughel racist
and maybe people who stand for the flag
are actually evidencing some sort of
brutal racism because of the but maybes
that we're all doing right now
everybody's in conflict if we just stuck
with you of courses and we skip the but
maybes we'd all be fine because we of
course we all agree on the stuff there's
no major disagreement on this stuff even
between people like me and Colin
Kaepernick okay he may not agree about
the the flag in the national anthem he
may not agree about those things we have
a serious disagreement there and we may
have a serious disagreement about police
procedure but we actually agree on the
value of dissent I assume I assume we
actually agree on that we at least go
half way but now we don't even go half
way now we're in total disagreement
because of the but maybes okay so you
can see the media is finally starting to
catch on to this game Trump is making
serious political hay here he's getting
people to rally around him you can see
that we'll show you in a second how the
NFL is really stuck between a rock and a
hard place but the media's Binion catch
on that Trump is playing a game and they
are falling for it here's CNN's Jim
Acosta the the least self-aware reporter
in America talking about how Trump
is from trying to wage a culture war is
he yeah you think this morning he's
putting out a tweet praising NASCAR
which obviously is geared towards a
different demographic and the way they
stand in respect and honor of the flag
is he trying to wage something of a
cultural war okay so he's here he's he
trying to wage a culture of first of all
the Left started this culture war by
politicizing sports I have been saying
this for years I have been saying this
for a long time
Trump did not start this war he has just
escalated the war that's all he's just
escalated the war and by the way this is
this notion that the the NASCAR has a
supremely different demographic from
football is just not really true
according to statistics in 2013 seventy
seven percent of the television audience
for the NFL was white seventy-seven
percent fifteen percent was black eight
percent was Hispanics the vast majority
of the NFL audience is still white so
the suggestion that Trump is doing this
because he hates black people I just
don't see the evidence of all that you
know it's it's it's kind of its kind
ridiculous in any case what's happened
now is because Trump has has polarized
the country even further than it already
was on this and then the left has
responded by polarizing even further by
saying that everyone has to kneel
everyone must kneel before Zod now the
NFL is stuck between a rock and a hard
place because their audience is 77%
white and there are a lot of people in
that audience white black and Hispanic
who are not interested in doing this
routine where they watch a bunch of
people protest that America is a racist
terrible terrible country they're not
interested in doing that routine so Rush
Limbaugh I think is actually good case
study not just because Russia's is a
right-winger obviously but because Rush
is the biggest football fan on radio I
mean he Russia's a super giant football
fan so much so that ESPN tried to have
him on Sunday NFL countdown about 15
years ago and here is Rush saying that
for the first time in a long time he
didn't watch any football on Sunday I
was personally said and I did not watch
the National Football League yesterday
and it was the first time in 45 years
that I made an active decision not to
watch including my team the Pittsburgh
Steelers it was not a decision made in
anger it was genuine sad
and it is said it is said these common
symbols are being ripped away if you're
an NFL owner or you're an NFL player
though you are stuck now between a rock
and a hard place because on the right
they're saying you need to stand for the
anthem and because Trump threatened
because Trump basically said I want
everyone to be fired the NFL should
change its rules let's boycott now if
you're an NFL player even if you don't
like the kneeling you feel the necessity
to stand by your teammates because if
you're playing on a team you tend to
stand by your teammates and their rights
if you're an NFL owner you don't want to
alienate the NFL Players Association nor
do you want to alienate your own players
by saying I'm gonna force you to stand
but at the same time if you don't force
your players to stand you're alienating
the audience so the Dallas Cowboys last
night tried to have it both ways the
Dallas Cowboys basically Jerry Jones
came out the owner of the team Trump
supporter he came out and he kneeled
down he knelt with with all the players
before the anthem so the idea was that
we're going to kneel to show free speech
rights and to demonstrate that we care
about equality and then during the
anthem we're gonna stand ups we're gonna
split the baby we won't Ashley Neal
during the anthem so we're not
disrespecting the anthem or the flag but
we are going to protest President Trump
by kneeling before the by kneeling
before the anthem the problem is
everybody in the stadium thinks that
Trump is sort of right about the
kneeling and so they say okay you're
really siding with all the players who
are kneeling before the anthem this is
the this is one of the dark places that
we've gone in sort of our First
Amendment discourse is if we don't like
how you exercise your First Amendment
rights then we suggest that you that the
First Amendment itself is the problem or
that if you stand up for the First
Amendment you're standing up for the
worst excesses of the First Amendment I
get this all the time you know I make
the case the people should be allowed to
speak on college campuses and then
people say so are you for Nazis saying
that they want to roast Jews and I was
like well no I'm not for that but they
have the right to say that kind of stuff
right we live in America right the
people do the same thing all the time
I'm the left right they they do this
with religious bakers when I say that I
think you should be able to own and
operate your business the way that you
see fit and then the left says what are
you for discriminating against black
people in gays I say well no no I'm not
actually for that I'm not for that at
all but you have a right to do what you
want with your own business rights and
inherently contain the capacity to
misuse those rights the problem is when
you symbolically stand up for the right
i parts
depending in the same sort of act as the
people who are misusing the right then
you're going to be lumped in with them
and that's what happened to cowboys last
night so here's what happened last night
with Jerry Jones and the cowboys and
listen to the crowd just wanted to show
unity but they were very adamant about
wanting to separate that message from
the national anthem
all right lease it as they take any
collectively booze can be heard from
this sellout crowd in Arizona and you
can hear the audience booing of course
and they are booing because again they
are identifying the kneeling because of
the symbolic because of the the
symbology the symbolism of the kneeling
the people are booing they weren't
booing until they now the minute that
they know people lump them in with Colin
Kaepernick and this is how this conflict
is gonna go for the NFL if you kneel
we're gonna lump you into Colin
Kaepernick if you don't kneel we're
gonna lump um with Trump these are the
two choices now we didn't have to make
that choice before but now that's the
choice that popular media are forcing us
to make it's the choice Trump wants to
make it's the it's the choice Pence
wants to make it's the choice that on
the Left Hillary Clinton wants you to
make they want you to pick sides are you
with LeBron James and Steph Curry and
Colin Kaepernick are you with Jerry
Jones and Bob Kraft or are you with
Donald Trump and Mike Pence and the
soldiers right that's the choice people
want you to make this is not a choice
you have to make you can be for the
soldiers don't kneel and you can also
not bit and you can also be for Colin
Kaepernick's right to kneel right can do
to both of these things but because the
NFL is trying to to thread this needle
they're gonna end up just destroying
themselves and you can see it yesterday
I paid homage to a guy named - Alejandro
Villanueva right Alejandro Villanueva
was an offensive lineman for the
Pittsburgh Steelers and he served three
tours in Afghanistan he was an Army
Ranger and he came out during the during
the anthem the rest of the Steelers team
stayed in the locker room Villanueva
came out and put his hand over his heart
for the anthem and I said well that's I
think a courageous move yesterday he was
forced to apologize after the left came
after an inch are pet that Villanueva
was just totally wrong
how dare Villanueva go out there alone
he humiliated his teammates Shannon was
feeling the way those rights were wrong
I believe he was wrong in this situation
skill I believe he put his personal
feelings and beliefs in front of that of
the team and this is a team now what we
know about the military the military
asked a man to put his life his or her
life in the hands of another man true
when you go outside of that protocol
people life are at risk that is correct
that's what a Colonel jessep said in a
few good men okay again this is so
stupid sorry I love the idea from
Shannon Sharpe
that how dare he how dare Villanueva put
himself ahead of his team his personal
feelings ahead of his team what do you
think Colin Kapernick was doing do you
think that he actually went through the
loop 49ers locker room and asked
permission before he did what he did so
you're allowed to put your opinion ahead
of the team when you're kneeling for the
anthem but you're not allowed to do that
when you are when you are standing up
for the American flag bill in a way that
ends up apologizing for all of this
because again this is the problem you're
either with now you're being forced to
make a choice you're the with your team
and therefore with Colin Kaepernick by
extension or you're with Donald Trump
that's a crappy choice most Americans
don't want to make that choice we're
gonna show you the tape of Illinois of
apologizing which I just think is awful
in one second but first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at frame
bridge so frame bridge is the easiest
way to custom frame your favorite art
and photos we've used it in our home we
sent some of our pictures directly from
our phone basically to frame bridge comm
you can upload your pictures directly on
computer to frame bridge they print them
out and send them to you in a beautiful
frame you go to frame bridge comm you
upload your photo from your computer or
from your Instagram feed or if you have
a physical item then they will provide
you prepaid packaging so you can mail it
in for free and then you can preview
your photo online and any frame style
choose your favorite they have talented
designers who will help you out as well
and they'll custom frame your item in
days not weeks or months and deliver it
directly to your door ready to hang so
none of that stupid screwing the stuff
in you know to the back of the frame
instead it's ready to hang as soon as it
comes into your door
the best part instead of the hundreds
that you'd pay at a framing store the
prices start at 39 bucks and all of the
shipping is free my listeners get 15%
off their first order at frame bridge
comm when they use my code Shapiro again
its frame bridge comm promo code Shapiro
they even offer a happiness guarantee if
you aren't a hundred percent satisfied
with your order they will make it right
we've used it in the Shapiro home it is
just terrific frame bridge comm use
promo code Shapiro and their prices are
much cheaper than it would be at some
retail outlet where you'd have to pay
the markup because you're going to wreck
to the supplier with frame bridge comm
frame bridge comm use promo code Shapiro
and save 15% off your forced order again
that's frame bridge comm promo code
Shapiro easy simple and inexpensive and
it looks nicer than anything else that
you'll get on the market okay so here is
here's this Pittsburgh Steelers
offensive lineman being forced to
apologize because he didn't stand by his
teammates cuz you either stand by the
people who are knee
or your you're a bad guy now Alice of
this plan very few players knew that I
was going to the tunnel because I only
asked the team leadership and so because
of that I didn't give them an
opportunity to stand with me mindful
that that is the very embarrassing part
am I in and what transpires because when
everybody sees an image of me standing
by myself everybody thinks that the team
of the Steelers are not behind me and
that's absolutely wrong it's quite the
opposite is they all would have actually
the entire team would have been out
there with me even the ones that want to
take a knee would have been there we
have they know these extreme
circumstances that at Soldier Field you
know the heat of the moment when I got
soldiers wooden veterans texted me that
you know that I have to be out there
then I think I think aside from every
single one of my team is no doubt so
because of that I've made Steelers ball
for not going out there and figuring
this thing out beforehand that's their
fault okay that's not Villanueva's job
to stay in the locker room with his
idiot teammates he won't come out for
the anthem if they want to come out and
lock arms and some of them Neal and some
of them don't that's fine
but to rip on and Villanueva's though he
did something totally wrong for coming
out after serving three tours in
Afghanistan all these guys can just you
know stick it where the Sun don't shine
really really obnoxious and again
this is the sort of thing where people
are not gonna watch the NFL because of
it so the NFL is gonna get absolutely
hammered in the ratings next week you
watch for it meanwhile the left is
getting more and more snarky about this
so as you see the posturing from some
people on the right about the flag and
the anthem and the idea that everybody
who is protesting in any way must hate
the flag and anthem which I don't think
is true I'm gonna show you some scorn
from the left that is truly off-putting
and demonstrative of just why what from
said is so effective politically but
we're gonna go through all that a
particularly spurs coach Gregg Popovich
said some pretty amazing things
yesterday LeBron James two will go
through all of it but for that you're
gonna have to go over to Daley wire comm
for $9.99 you can get your subscription
to daily wire comm you get the rest of
this show live you get the Michael
mole's show live at 12:30 today get the
Andrew Clavin show live at 10:30 go
check out drew strophe
yet it's really clever and it's really
fun and it's really interesting and he
always has great takes to check out
Drew's show I'll put that in the thing I
like but I mention it every day so go
check out Drew's show as well for $9.99
a month you get a subscription for all
of that and you also if you get the
annual subscription ninety nine dollars
a year then you get this the leftist
here's hot or cold mug which is quite
delightful at holding beverages and
liquids of all sorts hopefully drinkable
so go check that out if you merely wish
to subscribe to our iTunes or SoundCloud
or YouTube please go ahead and do that
and leave us a review we always
appreciate it we are the largest fastest
growing podcast in the nation
[Music]
all right so the left's corn is truly
astonishing and this is the part where
Trump triggered the left into making the
mistake of going full Kapernick never go
full Kapernick again the winning
strategy for the left here was we stand
with the right of people to kneel even
if we disagree with their kneeling
that's the proper strategy the left
cannot help themselves and so they feel
the necessity to rip America generally
so here's gregg popovich was a very left
guy
the coach of the San Antonio Spurs very
brusque fellow is talking about how
America is an embarrassment to the world
now we're countries an embarrassment in
the world this is this is an individual
actually thought that when people held
arms during the games that they were
doing it to honor the flag that's
delusional absolutely delusional but
it's what we have to live with so you
got a choice we can continue to bounce
our heads off the wall with his conduct
or we can decide that the institutions
of our country are more important that
people are more important that the
decent America that we all thought we
had and want is more important and get
down to business at the grassroots level
and do we have to do okay the idea that
everybody is embarrassed by the United
States first of all the idea that we're
in embarrassments the world to whom
well we embarrass the Germans whoopty
frickin do like anyone cares about that
will be embarrassing Bob why we
embarrass Communist China to embarrass
Putin like who do we embarrass we
embarrass Syria those sorts of
statements are so obnoxious that they're
just ridiculous and then Popovich said
stuff away he went on to say that if
you're a white person in America you
never understand what it's like to be
black if that's the case you cannot have
a functioning Republic the whole point
of a functioning Republic is that you
can think beyond your own self-interest
and think about what's good for the
country and try to get in the head of
somebody else and get in their shoes the
idea that inherently if you're a black
person that you can if you're a white
person you can never understand what
it's like to be somebody black well
that's really stupid particularly
because there are lots of different
types of white people and lots of
different types of black people it plays
directly into the racist
stereotypes that underlie Kaepernick's
nonsense and this is again this is where
the left is going the left is fully
embracing the radicalism now Trump has
forced them out of the closet and
they're embracing the radicalism dan
Patrick talk-show host he says you know
the American flag it's just not the same
thing to black Americans and white
Americans the flag represents something
different to other people
certainly white people can look at it go
that flag hey my father fought my dad
was marine I mean I might have to sit
down and have a discussion if my father
were alive to say this is what's going
on but hopefully you could have a
dialogue that says this is why they're
doing it
it's not about the flag it's about far
more than that to them the flag is not
the same thing to them as it is to us
and I'm saying white America the flag is
not the same thing to black people as it
is white people really I think the flag
is the same thing to everybody I think
that we should all have as Americans we
have a common stake in the future of the
country and in the history of ideas in
the country
I don't think that unity is impossible
in the country see this is where I I
divide from the left and I divide from
President Trump I don't think that unity
is impossible on these sorts of issues I
think that we can find unity in saying
the American flag stands for what's best
about America and we are always
attempting to perfect the country in
pursuit of that goal and we shouldn't
protest the one symbol that we hold in
common and we have so few now as it is
but again the left to the left to
radicalism it's just when people say the
Trump is the divider Trump is a divider
he's not the divider there are a lot of
people who are quite divisive LeBron
James decides that he has to sound off
to now and here's LeBron talking about
how stupid voters are American voters
are for voting for Trump I don't think a
lot of people was educated and and I
think that's the biggest one of the
biggest problems that we haven't when it
becomes a vote time that people are just
not educated on either the individual or
what's actually going on in the state of
the world right now
not like that particular state but in
the state of the world I don't think a
lot of people are educated and they make
choice they make choices and say things
that's uneducated
educated this from from from LeBron
James the people wasn't educated weren't
ya again like that's not just being
snarky saying to people that they are
uneducated about their vote and that's
why they're voting the way that they are
maybe they just have different
principles than you maybe they have
different beliefs maybe the different
sources of information than you but
again this is all super polarizing stuff
as I said yesterday LeBron James ripping
other people on their level of education
yeah I went directly from high school to
the NBA okay I'm in the he may be an
intelligent guy you know I have I have
no evidence that he's a dumb dumb but I
would not put I would not put my vote on
the peg of education if I went directly
from high school to the NBA and that was
my entire experience in in higher
education again don't use that you can
say that that people are making stupid
stupid votes that that I think is fair
on every side but to say uneducated when
your educational background is what
LeBrons is I think a little bit ironic
at the very least so again the left
falling into Trump's trap by becoming
ever more radical as part of Trump's
trap Jesse Williams who's an actor that
nobody's heard of since he did what it
was he on Grey's Anatomy or something
and he hasn't done anything since but he
hangs out so that he can say things
about how America's terrible every so
often on MSNBC so they took him out of
storage they unmasked balled him and
then they and then they talked to him
about the national anthem protests I
think Thomas it's also important to
realize that this anthem thing is a scam
this is not actually part of football
this was invented in 2009 as from the
government paying the NFL to market
military recruitment to get more people
to go off and fight wars to die this is
not nothing to do with NFL or American
pastime or tradition this is to get boys
and girls to go fly overseas and go kill
people in the military so ugly and ask
people to join the military you know the
military that defends this morons right
to speak how dare the military go to the
NFL crowd and and make as though the
military is a useful thing just
horrifying so again Trump has told the
left into being as left as it possibly
can be and at the same time he has made
an unprincipled right give up on certain
principles like the President of the
United States should not be interfering
with private business operations they
given up on that because it's more
important to
to shout about the flag in the national
anthem so yes everything remains just as
stupid as it was yesterday again no
Disneyland okay time for some things I
like and then some things I hate and
then we'll deconstruct some culture so
things that I like today
Peter Thiel who is a he was a trump
supporter he is the founder of the
co-founder of PayPal he's an investor in
facebook he's one of the top minds in
Silicon Valley and his original
investment group in PayPal included
people like Elon Musk it's like every it
was like seven members and all of them
have started billion-dollar companies a
brilliant guy Peter Thiel he wrote a
book called zero to one notes on
startups or how we build the future and
it's a really good book it's a short
books about 180 pages very quick read
but it's got some deep thoughts about
how you ought to think about your
business and how you ought to think
about your life and what I like about
feel is that he's very optimistic in his
vision for people taking control of
their own lives he's very libertarian
Thiel and SMI so that means that we have
a lot in common and and I think that
Peters book is quite good so go out and
pick up the book zero and one by Peter
Thiel okay other things that I like you
know this thing belongs in things I hate
so this will be the shortest things I
like ever lets you go directly to things
I hate okay so let's begin with Bernie
Sanders Bernie Sanders did a debate on
health care last night with Bill Cassidy
and Lindsey Graham which is just I mean
that's that's basically TV death and you
turn in for five minutes
and and then the ratings must have been
great on CNN for this thing because
people tuned in for five minutes and
they died at their remote so arbitron
and nielsen were still registering that
they were watching because they have no
idea they're dead in any case
poni Sanders of Vermont he explains that
health care is a right why is health
care right because everybody else says
it's right but that is not good enough
our job now is to come together to craft
serious short-term solutions that
addresses the real problems that exist
like deductibles high co-payments high
premiums high costs the prescription
drugs but longer-term
we have got to come together and finally
conclude that it's a nation we cannot be
the only nation major nation on earth
not to see healthcare as a right thank
you very much
not be the only major nation on earth
not to see abortion as a right we cannot
be the only major nation on earth not to
spend 80 percent of our GDP on social
programs what is this nonsense about we
can't be the only major nation on earth
to do X or Y or Z we cannot be the only
Bernie Sanders circa 1775 we cannot be
the only major nation on earth not to
have a king we must have a king everyone
else has the king why cannot we have a
king have they even created pudding yet
I do not think so so the this notion
that that we are going to declare
healthcare right because France declares
healthcare right is the stupidest crap I
ever heard make an affirmative case for
why saying that is going to make
healthcare better but don't say that
just because other nations say stuff
therefore we ought to say stuff I mean
this falls into the same category is
Popovich saying that we're an
embarrassment to the world yeah we only
provide half the world's economic growth
yeah we're the embarrassments of the
world okay other things that I hate so
there is an unbelievable ah panting the
New York Times today I don't know what's
going on over at the New York Times
editorial page but they have obviously
decided that it is deeply important to
promote communism in the last several
months they've run the following
headlines when communism inspired
Americans April 29 2017 when the Harlem
Renaissance went communist August 21st
2017 socialism's future maybe it's past
June 26th mm mm 17 and of course why
women had better sex under socialism
August 12th 2017 today's entry okay this
is what they tweeted out for all its
flaws the Communist revolution taught
Chinese women to dream big for all its
flaws let me read that again slowly so
that you understand how stupid this is
for all its flaws the Communist
revolution taught Chinese women to dream
big yes it taught them to dream big and
then die okay the the Great Leap Forward
cost 40 million lives overall Chinese
communism has cost 65 million dead
people 35 million of those are probably
women a forced abortion in China has
caused the death of by some reports of
at least a hundred and ninety-one
million female babies a hundred and
ninety-one million female babies aborted
since the Communist revolution in China
according to some studies which means
that right now China has a shortfall in
women they've 30
thirty to forty million more men than
women in China which is actually a
serious demographic problem when
countries tend to have far more men than
women they're more likely to be
militarized and go to war because you
got a lot of horny guys hanging around
who aren't married and don't have
families but the New York Times op-ed
says no no you don't understand
communism was great for women so here's
the glowing reminisce quote the
Communists did many terrible things my
grandmother always says at the end of
her reminisces but they made women's
lives much better that oft-repeated
dictum sums up the popular perception of
Mao Zedong regarding women in China as
every Chinese school child learns in
history class the Communists rescued
peasant daughters from urban brothels
and ushered cloistered wives into
factories liberating them from the
oppression of Confucian patriarchy
patriarchy and imperialist threat you
know what actually has created women's
rights capitalism gang na communism
capitalism or women freer today
Communist China or the United States or
France or Britain or Germany or Denmark
all of which are capitalist countries ok
Denmark is far more like the United
States than it is like like China in
terms of how its economy is run this
notion that women were liberated
liberated to do what starve this is all
reminiscent of how the left talks about
people like Fidel Castro no Chavez at
least before people are eating dogs in
the streets of Venezuela Fidel he
brought health care he brought health
care to the people sure thousands of
them are in prison for descent sure
they're they hate the island so much
they're attempting to float off the
island with 1950s cars and the tires
inflated sure but he had health care
didn't he and literacy went up it's so
ridiculous
ok the the here's what it says says
while the communist revolution brought
women more job opportunities it also
made their interest subordinate to
collective goals stopping at the
household doorstep mouths words and
policies did little to alleviate women's
domestic burdens like housework and
childcare so didn't do anything just
told women that they could be leaders of
the re-education camps again the New
York Times propping up communism is
quite an amazing sight so the left
really really out of the closet on this
stuff now ok time for a little bit of
deconstructing the culture so
deconstructing the culture today why
don't we begin with this incredible
video you were talking about scorn of
one side for the other there's a video
that's now come out with a few actresses
I don't actually know some of these
actresses I guess one of them is Ellen
Page I'm not sure who the other
actresses are here but they cut a video
for the a/v Club and the onion talking
about they're not going to date Trump
supporters you know good luck with that
it's like the bubble that the
self-righteous bubble these people have
created it's quite amazing
and now the sports world is bubbling
itself off in the same way that the
entertainment world is that there's a
Sports Illustrated cover showing a bunch
of people in sports we all stand
together Hollywood does this routine we
all stand together guess what the rest
of America thinks you're just awful so
here's this little video with Ellen Page
and unnamed other people who I will find
out in just a moment saying they would
never date a trump supporter but I think
in the end they you know everyone's
starting to see sort of what's happening
and I want to go on because I can go
under for way too long but like no no I
don't think I could get it you're a
trump supporter well at any point
because you've been saying this the
whole time but by this point I'm sorry
no okay no we've never dated Trump
supporters just never do it okay it's
kate mara and Ellen Page and Amy Simon
so we're in a new movie that looks awful
called my days of mercy which looks just
terrible kate mara and Ellen Page play
lovers on the opposite ends of the
political spectrum pages Lucy a woman
who is vehemently opposed to the death
penalty while Mara's mercy is in support
of it good luck all right so you wonder
why Americans look at Holly wouldn't
they say we want no part of you this is
why you want to write movie receipts her
down part of it is because the movies
are crappy part of is because the
tickets are expensive and part of it is
because you people keep alienating us
and annoying us can the same thing is
about to happen in the sporting world in
other entertainment news the Amazon has
decided that it is imperative to show
full frontal transgender full frontal
nudity on TV they really did this in the
the other day they show a the person in
the rear of this photograph is a man who
has had a boob job
that's all that's happened here
Alexandra Billings is the name of this
of this actual transgender person who is
in transparent and and so they I don't
know if we just have the picture or if
there's the actual scene I hope just the
picture because I don't actually want to
see the scene in any case this person
turns around
and has breasts and a penis and this is
supposed to be some sort of some sort of
step forward for the transgender
community now we're all supposed to I
love the descriptions in the media it's
pretty amazing in the media in The Daily
Beast they say thing it's just it's just
incredible because we really wanted to
show her penis her penis excuse me yeah
so on the one hand is again this is just
pushing more cultural boundaries that
we're supposed to pretend that all of
this is that this person is actually a
woman but on the other hand there is
something to the idea that the shocking
vision of a of a man with breasts will
may dissuade some folks that this is
actually a woman because when you see
that that does not eat that that's
clearly a man so good good job Amazon
for for creating programming that just
yeah what's the point of all this what's
the point of all this I mean this is
just what they do okay final final note
on deconstructing the culture I have no
words for these things final note
there's a movie called mother and our
own Michael Mills who's wrong about
virtually everything is wrong about this
too he says that the movie mother is
just a wonderful biblical allegory so
the movie is a biblical allegory Darren
Aronofsky is the worst director ever
Darren offski is hot garbage Darren
Aronofsky is the emoji movie shot on a
handheld camera and with people shooting
up that's Darren Darren Aronofsky every
Darren Aronofsky movie is the same it's
all hysterical and ludicrous and filled
with looks inside people's heads that no
one cares about it's always a dark
creepy place cuz Darren Aronofsky's a
weirdo
okay his new movie mother is another one
of these routines in the same line by
the way if you ever want to watch a
truly awful film go watch no I know as a
truly awful film that does not
understand the Bible and so he's made a
new film that's basically in the same
vein it's Jennifer Lawrence and Javier
Bardem hard Javier Bardem plays a writer
with writer's block who's supposed to
obviously be God Jennifer Lawrence is
supposed to be the Virgin Mary in this
allegory it's such a bad movie that
CinemaScore gave it an F okay you know
how to get an F on cinema score you know
you know how much you have to disappoint
audiences to get an F on cinema score
you have to basically shoot them in the
head okay to get an F on cinema score
like the audiences will give it
they'll give lay like night out
like that crappy Scarlett Johansson film
those knockoff at The Hangover look at
that b-minus on on cinema score it's got
an F and I got an F because it it
degrades into this bizarre orgy of blood
and violence and fire and the whole idea
is supposed to be that humanity man and
woman come to this house with that's
owned by Javier Bardem and Jennifer
Lawrence an they start ruining the house
and making everything terrible and all
these people start showing up because
humans are a scourge on the earth which
was the same message that he promised he
promoted in Noah which is garbage here's
the preview they tried to pitch this as
a horror film because they knew nobody
would want to watch a movie about how
human beings are garbage and ruin the
earth so instead they tried to promote
this in the normal horror film
we spend all our time here I want to
make a paradise she redid all of it
every last detail when she breathed life
back into everyone here happy I love you
[Music]
please coming hello hey look a shaky cam
thanks Derek Ranger right just gonna let
him sleep in our house hello hello did
you know he had a wife it's creepy are
they ghosts is the house haunted no it
turns out none of that crap is true it's
just all a really bad biblical allegory
for a guy who has never really studied
the Bible in any depth and and I believe
Aronofsky's a self proclaimed proclaimed
atheists Oh note to self proclaimed
atheists please stop making religiously
allegorical movies you don't know what
the hell you're talking about
okay I'm not making an atheist film I
would suggest that you not make a
religious film if you don't know what in
the world you're talking about more
evidence that Hollywood hates the
country and that's exactly what
Aronofsky said by the way he said the
audience's don't get it because they're
illiterate
yeah thanks guys they I can't imagine
why all of us are turning off our TVs
and ignoring you okay we'll be back here
tomorrow with the latest in the
stupidity vortex as it continues to
build into that category 5 hurricane
that will wipe all intellectual life
from the planet roof do better today
guys tomorrow by the way we'll be in
Utah so if you're a University of Utah I
think we're sold out but there may be
overflow rooms so check it out but we'll
see you there if you dar I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
you